valérie je t'aime
hier j'étais vidé j'ai dit qu'il était
une [ __ ]
mais en fait c'est pas vrai reviens tu
es bon en fait t'es pas une [ __ ] et
qu'une salade mais je t'aime quand même
alors revient à quelqu'un que j'aime
très fort alors cette personne n'est pas
loin dans paris eh ben moi j'aime pas
dire des messages des mots que tout le
monde comprend donc j'ai décidé sur un
code d'amour un taux de que personne ne
comprend et ça rend les gens toujours
ahuri comme tu m'entends dire jt ap xxl
et je sais qu'il n'y a qu'une personne
qui la comprend et voilà donc ces seuls
mots d'amour que j'ai à dire et je crois
que ça risque de toucher une personne
très près de moi qui qui comprend ce que
ça veut dire puisqu'il a composé avec
moi voilà c'est tout retenons s'il vous
plaît catherine à ses superbes catherine
j'aime bien vous voulez passer dans le
mien par hasard c'est tara c'est bien
donc ça va très bien qu'on physique
lorsque
on attendait que je suis vous et vous me
trouvez comment physiquement power sans
plus elle s'appelle marie mais
malheureusement elles émanent autre
garçon
et
je vais la voir demain pour qu'elle
m'explique ce qui se passe pourquoi ne
même plus pourquoi ne veut plus de moi
voilà je suis très triste je suis dans
une très belle ville mais je suis pas
très heureux quand elle reprend en at il
requis ch'tis astres savennières ma
chère femme chambas
il ment terre tortin ma fille je
t'embrasse et tyra hayemaker ça veut
dire mes petits enfants
jean-marc les juges
je t'embrasse et pis ma petite fille
carol rich des pistes en brasse voilà à
mon grand père à ma grand mère je sais
je leur souhaite qu'ils se rétablissent
le plus vite possible et qui reviennent
chez eux rapidement parce que c'est eux
qui me font à manger et tous les midis
alors après 102 moi je mange parce qu'un
là je veux dire quand ils sont là si
elle qui me fait à manger a fait du très
bon manger alors c'est celle qui m'a
élevé quoi alors je veux qu'elle
revienne vite à la maison quoi je dois
souhaiter un excellent anniversaire à
mon père oui oui il ça il habite à
epinay sur seine
et c'est ça ce genre de 12e année et
et comme j'arrive pas à lui parler
j'aimerais lui parler par l'intervenante
de la caméra et il souhaitait encore des
bonne et heureuse année
voilà j'ai de très bons souvenirs de toi
sylvie j'espère que ta vie va bien et
que tu te portent bien
je te fais un gros bisou
bonjour christine david c'est votre papa
je suis à paris là en ce moment là je
pense très fort à vous j'espère vous
voir bientôt
oui jésus je t'aime et je veux te mets
plus aujourd'hui
et puis demain est chaque jour davantage
jésus je t'aime mon chien je considère
comme mon propre fils c'est à dire que
pour lui ce n'importe quoi
il est malade bon ben je conduire chez
le vétérinaire sans savoir combien
d'argent j'ai dépensé pour lui cet amour
c'est plus fort qu'un amoureux envers un
fils enfin je ne sais pas je dis ça
parce que j'ai un chien mais cet amour
les il est plus fort de tous ces quelque
chose qui en soi qu'on ne peut pas
déterminer qu'on ne peut pas délimitée
j'aurais aimé beaucoup avoir un enfant
dont malheureusement n'ont pas pu avoir
mais un jour ou l'autre je pense que ça
viendra et je lance un message très
profond est vraiment du fond du coeur
une petite fille qui je pense sera paix
joliette comme maman s'appelait donc ton
qui est des fentes maintenant à et voilà
je l'aurais je pense que j'aimerais
toute ma vie et je pense en avoir une à
jour mon très cher époux que je vous
aime et je ne vous oublie pas ainsi que
monsieur jacques matin que je connais
très bien
j'aime beaucoup son édition que je vis
et bravo à monsieur jacques martin je
souhaite à tous il a tout loupé l'ordre
[Musique]